I was so curious um with the email it's
at some point it showed like the amount
you were spending per month on like all
that stuff could you break that down
like everything
I want to spend that just break
everything down and then tell us where
we can get the Canadian version for way
cheaper
with another Silver Lining yeah Derek
sent my email shared my email with the
world
do you know how many pharmacies and
Clinics have reached out and said you're
paying double the amount you know how
much money I'm already saving you know I
just upgraded I got into the hotel
yesterday you guys saved you 60 000 a
year more than that we upgraded yeah
we're going to Florida after this
upgrade [ __ ] hotel but
um all the money's in the growth
ornament you know like the
testosterone's 100 a month oh
testosterone's 100 for three months
so testosterone doesn't cost anything
it's very cheap the peptides that I had
taken um that all the peptides are long
gone you know though I tried all these
peptides to try and increase my growth
hormone none of that worked my growth
hormone never registered any kind of
bump my igf-1 levels which is a kind of
a long-term indicator of what your
growth hormone is over time A lot of
times people go take a growth hormone
test it might not register anything
because it's so volatile over time so
igf-1 is like okay what's your growth
hormone long-term what has it been like
you know for for like I don't know the
last six weeks or something maybe I'm
wrong about that but whatever
um the money that I spend is really on
the growth hormone right like when he
says that number that's on the growth
hormone yeah people have been asking me
um so how much do you actually spend
I'll tell you this I mean it's enough to
buy a car every month that's how much it
is you know but but now I get to say 50
thank you yeah you know but but again my
goal is to save 100 you know like I'm
I'm getting off this and uh and my goal
is to save 100 but so the number he
shared was pretty accurate and how did
you feel the day you found out that he
had made this documentary about you like
you woke up in the morning you saw it
and no no you know what happened I was
sitting
ironically maybe not ironically I was
sitting on the Pew inside of my house
it's a really dark space and so I'm
sitting on on this Pew and it's probably
8 30 at night this is when I go to bed
Church Pier yeah the church you have a
church inside of your house we have a
church pew inside of the house oh just
the Pew
um
I have special moments there okay and
it's also a place it's dark it's just a
sacred place to be yeah yeah so I'm
going to bed and I and I just look just
to make sure every night I make sure any
emergencies any emergencies you know and
you know 19 out of 20 times no
emergencies will go to bed
um so anyways I I turn on my phone and
uh like a WhatsApp group that I was like
do we need to get crisis management
involved and I'm like okay here we go
again I mean because this happens all
the time right and and um somebody sent
the link I hit play and I'm like okay
Derek's already made five videos right
so I'm like okay here's another video so
I respond I don't have [ __ ] time for
this I'm going to bed somebody responds
go to minute 32. I go to bed at 32 and
my heart starts going and I go wife
she comes over she sits right here
I watched two minutes of it yeah the
holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
and uh and so again the immediate
reaction is like okay no point crying
over spilled milk like you can't
fabricate this yeah you know the the
this is I mean he reads everything that
I wrote like you can't fabricate this
thing you know and so I didn't watch the
rest of the video that day
um but what I did do is is I got in
touch with I called them again to say
thank you I don't know what good will
come of this you know this this is why
you know I've achieved the success that
I have like one of my super powers is
focus okay we did that no no points you
know crying over that like this is what
I gotta do you know so I started
developing my path forward and again
like when you Express gratitude and
appreciation at the same time you can't
live a life of scarcity you can't live
in a life of fear you can't hate people
at the same time right so if you're
grateful and you expand you know and you
live up that that philosophy of
abundance you can't do the two at the
same at the same time so um so that's
what I thought about it that's how I
handled it and I slept like [ __ ] that
night I slept like [ __ ] right next day
we talked to crisis management you know
what does that mean some PR you know
guys like here's how you handle the
crisis here's what you're going to say
I'm like well hold on I was like anybody
who knows me knows I would never say
anything like this yeah I'm not gonna
and they took out all my all the curse
words and stuff you know first of all
they said what would you say well this
is what I said to my family yeah and
they said well this is not what you're
gonna say to the public yeah like what
what do you think I'm gonna say you know
and and so then it just seemed like some
[ __ ] Legacy Media apology and I'm
like you think I'm going to say anyone
who knows me knows that I would never
talk like that yeah what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna say the same thing that I said
to my family and so it was just clear to
me I'm like okay as long as I make sure
everything is revealed right now this is
my opportunity to do this yeah so the
fast forward to me became pretty [ __ ]
clear pretty [ __ ] quick yeah you know
and then every day it seems like it got
clearer and clearer and every day I'm
um feeling a little bit better did you
talk to your
um the guy who was supplying you with
the stuff that leaked the email have you
spoken to him since and and how do you
feel about him leaking your email you
know this is really interesting
um I call them the client pound coach
because here's the thing I just saw a
video
about him saying that everything on my
apology was a lie yeah he just made a
video about that um he's your coach
though like well this is real
interesting he tries to say he wasn't
because he refunded my money and he
wasn't actually my coach this is what he
said I'm sure after this got leaked and
I'm sure after they mentioned his name a
lot of his coaching clients left and
said or concerned so he probably tried
to make a public appearance to say oh no
I wasn't actually his coach I refunded
his money which is total [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know well is that for
illegal reasons I don't know I don't
know and the truth is I don't really
care you know it's like people like hey
aren't you gonna Sue X Y and Z I'm like
for what well why would I sue anybody
yeah and and I want to make it really
clear this guy was never my dealer this
guy didn't Supply anything I I was being
monitored and met I had an actual
Hormone Clinic and a clinician that was
over and so here's the problem is like
my blood chemistries were [ __ ] up and
I actually needed help you know and this
is why it's so important if you're going
to touch any of this [ __ ] if you're on
any [ __ ] get managed by an actual
professional because my lip bids were
all [ __ ] up my liver enzymes were high
and uh so I sent to this guy this coach
and I sent an email to Derek I saw that
I said Derek has had this for a year and
a half yeah yeah that's funny anyways uh
looking for help hey what do I need to
do you know because my current clinician
I felt like
What's it gonna hurt if I get some more
opinions these guys know this [ __ ] let
me reach out to these guys so I enlisted
his help
um you know helped me out for a while
but I'll tell you he never [ __ ] and
refunded my money listen I'm not asking
for the money back you know uh it to me
it's like okay he did what he did Derek
did what he did like
now I'm in a possession again
um I'm not apologizing because I got
caught I'm apologizing because what I
did was wrong getting caught has this is
my reality I'm facing my reality they
help me come to my reality they're
helping me express my truest self you
know one of the other Silver Linings I I
I've alluded to this before is um
you know my kids I'm sure have thought
that I'm like a larger than life figure
you know and and they get to see me drop
to my [ __ ] knees